actualité jérard Larcher l'affaire Joë
garot le sénateur de Loire Atlantique a
été mis en examen car il est accusé
d'avoir drogué la députée Sandrine joso
afin je cite de commettre un viol ou une
agression sexuelle vous lui avez demandé
dans un courrier de prendre ses
responsabilités et de se mettre en
retrait de ce mandat de son mandat de
sénateur et de démissionner de ses
fonctions de secrétaire du Sénat et de
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères est-ce qu'il vous a
répondu écoutez d'abord je voudrais
rappeler que c'est h égard à la gravité
des faits et à la dig de la fonction de
parlementaire et qu'au nom de ça j'ai
jugé qu'il était de mon devoir de
demander à ce parlementaire de
démissionner de démissionner de deux
fonctions éminentes au Sénat secrétaire
du bureau du Sénat
et vice-présidente de la Commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées je lui ai demandé de se
mettre en retrait mais je m'applique un
principe tant qu'il n'y a pas eu de
décision de justice la présomption
d'innocence la deuxième des choses c'est
que le Sénat collabore pleinement à
l'enquête qui est conduite et je
rappelle que seule la justice peut
démettre de son mandat un parlementaire
mais je vous dis la question de
l'éthique et de la déontologie est pour
moi essentielle voilà pourquoi j'ai
demandé à ce sénateur retirer vous navez
pas de réponse de gar écoutez il m'a
fait une lettre
je la transmettrai dans le cadre de
l'enquête à qui de droit et si jamais il
refuse de démissionner du bureau du
Sénat est-ce que vous lu
contraindrait la même chose protection
du mandat je pense qu'il est entré dans
une phase de réflexion personnelle qui
pourrait répondre au principes que
j'exige
déontologie et éthique de la part des
parlementaire et sans faiblesse donc
cette réponse de Joel gario vous allez
la transmettre aux enquêteurs à quiis de
droit c'est
c'est ma responsabilité et j'assumerai
mes responsabilités pour ceux qui me
connaissent j'ai plutôt l'habitude de
les assumer merci beaucoup jar